hi Timothy really from war from research
and today I'll be speaking about
training on large data set which is
mostly about remote training of neural
networks
I think we're living the world of the
nice and polished presentation to go to
the work of the scripting and several
lines of code area and I think we're
going to take risk and live on the edge
because it's presentation heavily
depends on networks and in connectivity
so that's likely to fail but let's see
what it's about it's about when you
train your own network and you reach the
stage when you're happy with what your
architecture looks like on your local
computer with toy example and you think
that it might be a good idea to start to
go big and end-to-end to train something
that is more like production industry
level right so several possibility
either you have the super duper laptop
with many GPUs loaded on it and an
incredible power and that's why you can
try a net that is very unlikely and
easily you have to go to to look for for
for for stronger machine and and then
this is the case we're going to deal
with which is either you have a strong
machine which is a server that you need
to access either you have to just rent
it from from from web services and and
generate this on-demand machine for the
time you need it so yeah why training
remotely it's indeed bit harder than
just do the net train on your computer
and scissors very nice and and moving
panels and but it can it's definitely in
terms of of training definitely leads
you to to to better
see and and metrics it goes much faster
if you massively paralyze your
computation which is typically typically
the GP world and in most of the time you
you will need to go to that when you
start to dig into hyper parameters
search you want to test several
architecture need that you want to
launch many many training at the same
time which is not necessarily big
trainings that many of them so you need
many machines so you need to go to
cluster for that or because you have the
hyper parameters architecture you're
interested in and you want to launch a
big one and you hope it's going to be
the big one that's okay
so a typical remote training workflow
it's it's the same four four four neural
network and this was the regular job on
clusters it's generally you have the
seven machine and your computer and
first step is to be able to communicate
with with with the server so you have to
exchange some secrets that so generally
is something called a keeper that lets
the server knows that it's you because
you can do things that also account do
so this is a little key and the little
lock here you need some the scripts of
the job you want to execute and enter
data file the data file is in case of
training what you do is that you send a
request to the server that's and uses
that that starts you to check whether
it's you and if you are able to identify
yourself as being you then you open a
paternal connection with the server and
you can move generally as an archive
your data to the server and when your
scripts and file are on the on the
remote server you will then launch start
to tell tells the server do to launch a
kernel and to evaluates the scripts on
your data and eventually the server will
generate some log file
and and some network that you will
download back to your computer so
because there is this connection
involved which can be messy can sometime
breaks and you get this pipe rock thing
then you don't want to do it
synchronously which is what you have
with a little nice panel if you just
connect your front end to your you can
definitely connect your front end to the
remote colonel and then just tighten it
trained and it will works for it will
work for probably few hours and and and
then after few hours of training you
would probably break because of the
connection or because you just closed
the lid of your laptop and it went to
sleep and and that's it and and you
don't want that after well I assume you
don't want that a few weeks of training
like things that breaks and and and
that's it so there are so as a
consequence you want to do this thing's
a synchronously and that's why I think
the best system is the good old one with
the script and so on that's what I'm
going to show you but you don't you
don't very often have like a server with
the latest GPU or if you do you're
spending like money every year to keep
it up-to-date and so on so the classic
way to do those things even industrial
scale is to actually use a service
provide the service provider which job
is to keep infrastructure of those seven
machine and what I'm going to show you
here is how to do that by on-demand
machine with Amazon Web Services which
we we use internally in the team so AWS
Amazon Web Services they they are they
provide a lot of services among which
you have the simple storage system also
known as s3 and s3 just you have a
collection when you create an account
you get the connection of
buckets in which you can put your data
and book it's just like a net an
endpoint you can access with a URL so
it's unique a unique identifier in
on the wall Amazon world system and what
you have inside is just a bunch of
objects so your data you files with some
key which you can see as the path to the
object within the Packer to to identify
them so that's as simple as that and
then you have the elastic cloud
computation so known as ec2 which is
which you can see as like giant racks of
of seven machines with many many
hardware that that are there and if if
you have some some image some virtual
machine image and configuration which
they call Amazon machine image which are
image of the machine configuration and
and and also it contains a snapshot
which is an image of what's what's
what's the hard drive which they call
volume contains then you can request a
virtual machine so with easy to create
instance which I'm going to show you
them a virtual machine to be to be to be
created out of this image and you end up
with as a virtual machine which is like
parts of the of the server that is
allocated to you an annual annual volume
volume which is the storage part with
the server that we were talking about up
there right so that's what we're going
to do and then the training workflow in
this case you have three components you
have the s3 where you store all your
data and it's cheap for very large
amount of data you have your local
computer and which you write your
scripts and you tests
hopefully you test them and and you have
this virtual machine that you that you
launch on the on the ec2 system and for
which you need to be able to identify
yourself
to communicate right so this is a
previously known as servers this is a
new guy which is a storage place and
with whom we need to communicate and
this is us so let's start with one of
the many local tests which is like the
krypter everyday life you do the script
it doesn't work you test it and you do
it again and again let's look at what I
have here on the machine and yeah you
know not not the this is supposed to
okay let's do it the old way so let's
just move to this so what I have here is
training data here a bunch of images and
within those training data
I also have three text files one text
file that is let's look at them right
that's not very conclusive there you go
so you have something like this that
tells which image is what which I call
the index right and I have some of them
which is a training deco with like data
that I want to use for training some Z
which is test D Co which is more like
validation set and I have another one
which is probably a dot M because it's
too easy when yeah which is the is the
list of possible outcomes for the
classification we're going to train a
classification on those on these data
set right and on top of that I have this
I have this script that's I can just run
so it's training straight and here we go
so we start the script so basically what
it does it it goes look at the look at
the data it will it will find the text
file and says ok this is this is what
what the index is and then it will look
for the images and with feed feed a net
train we will look at that afterward and
we can so this is running on my on my
local GPU and it seems to work the
training started and I will probably
have this little result folder here that
start to contains what I call checkpoint
which are image of the Netta - given
configuration and I have these tab
separated value report which is exactly
what you see here about how the training
is going on and and and here we go and
eventually I will save the results the
result of the of the training ones done
right so this is a very good point which
means that we can start to think about
moving to the - - what we actually want
to do which is a remote so for the
remotes
what we'll have to do so the script is
working if I have my data locally so
what we have to do is so we have these
buckets with a like bunch of files which
is exactly the same configuration with
what I showed you and I on my local
machine but you can have many many more
files and there is this text this train
and test dictionary indexes which are
there we get to move we got to move
those data to the ec2 machine we get to
launch this this this virtual machine we
get to move the script there and so we
have a bit of a policy privilege to set
up you know the for the machine to be
able to talk to to s3 we get to say oh
it's okay you can assume you can you can
work on my behalf
you can use my role and we get to make
sure when we start the ec2 machine that
we have already set this this key so
that we can identify that and talk
directly to the machine
right so here we go training complete
exporting training result and that's and
that set the local scripts seems to work
and that's things that was the easiest
one because there is no connection
involved here so let's do this let's
let's generate this machine and I will
show you AWS link which is a wrapper
that I wrote around the Amazon store
that development kit to do this and then
let's just do the training remotely so
let's launching an incense what do you
do that first you will need AWS link and
which is in the layout also we don't
export it so we want its cottagey we
engage to maintain it's just a wrapper
for now and then with just very quick
configuration this is to say here is the
configuration of the machine that I want
to use that something you specify the
first so this is an this is a
configuration in which Mathematica is
already installed the old way I just
moved Mathematica binnorie I installed
this I installed it and I activated it
then I did this image that let me launch
as like instances
that's repeat exactly the same
configuration this is just the road
which means that the machine is going to
be able to speak to s3 in my name so I
have identification and this is the name
of the of the keeper you know the little
lock little key in order to be able to
talk to the to the machine right and in
few tags which are just like some some
internal stuff just saying that I am
running this machine for for my group so
they don't cheat it ok so we have this
yeah see the instance owner is me that's
quite easy ok and so the easy to create
instance that I use the base
configuration from the launch template
so I don't have to specify the mi and
the instance privilege and the key I'm
going to use to talk with the machine
let's try this
oops debugs some debug Eko from
yesterday late evening so here we good
we got the this this instance that
Amazon generated for us as simple as
that and we can just have the public dns
name that we use to connect to it that's
a machine address can you look at it
state it's currently running we can and
if we use data sets we can have like all
the parameter of of the instance this is
a fairly powerful instance with three
with two GPU 300 right
so I created so I'm in this state here
where the instance is here it's I it's
got the key to to identify me there's a
and we are exactly here right now let's
let's let's move the script and let's
move the data from from from s so this
data move is going to be part of the
script but I have to move the script to
the machine so super simple again let's
let's do it connecting to the instance
you can do it from the terminal you know
SSH and and and so on or you can use
remote connects from Mathematica so what
you need to provide the server address
the DNS and just provide the pass on
your local computer where the private
key is is is buried and hidden and I
won't show you and and there we go we
got a remote connection object that is
that the tunnel is is ready and so we
can sense some whoopsie so we can send
some comment to see what it looks like
this is a just list content at the root
of my machine and a Caesar still this
Linux installation remainings of I
should have clean things so I can do it
let's clean my home directory and you
know it's just like giving the machine
and showing the command as in command
line let's see
okay
and let's try to exec execute some some
some yeah okay
it's a bit slow yeah connection let's
try to execute a dummy script that is
just like 2+2 and see whether the system
is able to answer so so we have we have
our machine and with the states then the
server is ready and we can launch a
training on it which we're gonna no I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna do writes
there which is here is the local files
that I have on a computer and here is
where I want to put it through SCP on
the on the machine I want to put it on
on my home and under the name training
scripts and this is a identification ok
so I I could move as a script to the
Machine and this is the URL on the
machine and now the only thing that I
have to do is to launch the scripts but
if I launch the script like just you
know run like I did here if the
connection skirts then there is no link
anymore and it would just die so I'm
gonna use a little trick that is to put
this screen system that says make it you
know standalone and run even if I
disconnect and but it's just like
launching the training script and here
we go exit cut zero stunner boots and
and now what I can do is to use it's a
bit hacky but if I you still just say
like here is the training log that
checks is it's a text file that my
script generates like what you've seen
in this in the terminal before and just
look at these guys the last 10 lines and
and and show me the contents creating
that so you see the script is running on
the machine and loading the testing data
lists it's creating a training progress
report loading the nets and and and very
soon we will see the training
let's well well this is going on let's
look at it
thank you a quick tour of what the
script look like sorry because this file
is created by the scripts I just cleaned
the home directory and no have this file
that I can and I can just update I can
just update the contents and see that
you know updating from come on guys
seriously so what I'm doing is I'm just
loading the wolf run what's the name
again image identify your nets with
nothing initialize it and training on
the on the data for classification so
well looks like he needs to get it first
but yeah we've seen and so so that's
that's the training script I guess is
the interesting part at the beginning of
it you have this remote job queue that
is just trying to see which machine it's
running whether it's a local test or not
depending on that I'm just like settings
a path to the data and see a bit a bit
differently and saying like on my
machine is going to be CPU with with the
shorts training time just for the test
and on the remote machine I'm just
setting the path to the bucket that that
that we created that I created this week
and in things that's going to be GPU
with with something that is much more
big in in scope then I'm doing this from
I'm sitting to put like everything under
control regarding anything that is alia
that is random and I'm starting here I'm
using AWS AWS come online as a run
process it's be tacky but it's just to
download to call and download the data
it's it's like the CP command from the
book from zero cat2222 the place ago so
I'm calling the remotes and I'm copying
to local for for for the for the text
files then I'm doing it for all the
images so this just moves
that from the buckets to my to my
computer to to my a to my say remote
machine to the - server I load I load
the dictionary as I was doing on a
computer and this is an interesting part
this is like how I generates a badge and
when I when I launch this job don't look
the data I carry on it's a synchronous
so I start downloading the data and I
launch the training so at the beginning
I have very few data and it gets bigger
and bigger so what I'm doing here is I
look for the for the file names and this
is a list that increase and and then I
just like just hit take I just take the
keys in my dictionary that are the files
that I already have and I start to train
with what I have and as it goes bigger
I'm something more and more data right
and and then I have this function for
check pointing judges just save image of
the net on on s3 rights and and this one
that generates the reports and there
here is a net creation so well from
image identify net we plus part to adapt
to the to the to the training and the
training is super easy it's just a net
train on the nets with my batch
generator that just like grab some pass
to the image that I have and in train
target device is G is GPU and training
providers function just you know from
time to time evaluates export trade
points and export training reports and
at the end of just printing so here is
for the scripts and so yeah I'm yet so
this generate generate batch yes
that's a very important point that
returns file pass in the case of image
because if I do input like input is
going to be slow on its it's a do
everything function so I try to avoid as
much as possible import for image if you
have a net encoder it will take care
doing it completely out of core and take
care says or here is the image I'm going
to load the data just when I need it and
I don't like load everything in memory
memory stay you know quite clean yep
what do you mean peril on the on the on
the on the deep yeah it's it's it's
running on so it's running on the on the
GPU which is a massive parallel system
with like hundreds and hundreds of core
doing this kind of convolution
computation at the same time yeah it's
exactly sorry if you're several nodes
this this would require you just to you
know
export the script to two to every nodes
and and lodge them on every node or have
a master script that just you know
distribute to the node but that's
something you can do if you have to
train for instance several configuration
of the network for for the for the for
the for the piper parameter search you
can definitely do that right but at the
moment what I create on ec2 is just one
machine is not a cluster you could
generate many many machine and have one
master node that distributes the jobs
like what I'm doing manually here but
yeah
[Music]
actually I think let's
[Music]
yeah you see download download data
result she has a test decode so there's
a download of the data happened as we we
can look for what's inside results so it
started the training report it seems
that's that's that's super bad
it seems that actually yes this is
updating from well from server research
like loading the nets is actually having
let's see sorry
no what what we see here it's what's
happening on ec2 so the script started
it's downloading that is done loading
data from s3 it's like everything's
worked fine but at the time that I am
NOT
I should have locally created my little
network architecture instead of trying
to you know like ask well from to do it
because what happened here is that well
friend said oh you're not up-to-date you
have a bunch of packets that I need to
update for and I have just 10 minutes so
it says like oh by the way have you seen
that neural network is a bit like you
know and which I should have so so it's
updating from from from the server and
as soon as see the data that will have
my network and stunning start and yes
exactly it's like I just fresh version
style Mathematica and says hi I need
this network that's that's and and and
and but but you see that the the
downloading of the data from from to s3
worked and and and indeed you are able
to upload when the training is done is
finished